Well, after a very chilly start to your Sunday, temperatures will warm up.
We're gonna see lots of sunshine today,...
...but dry conditions; it will be a very beautiful and pleasant day.
But moisture levels will rapidly increase as we head into the workweek,...
...so our humidity will come up Monday, Tuesday into Wednesday.
So enjoy it while you can.
And then the next front moves through on Thursday...
...and our best chance for rain, Wednesday into Thursday.
Highs today that will warm up nicely will be 78 in Seminole, 77 in St. Pete...
...79 in Oldsmar, 79 in Tampa.
Northern counties still warming up nicely too, Crystal River and Hernando,...
...both at 77 and the rest of the bay area stays in the upper 70s.